bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
depuis l'écho ce numéro est consacré aux
métiers anciens des métiers dans les
techniques de travail sont quasi
identiques à celles utilisées il ya des
centaines d'années que découvriront
l'intérêt de conserver ses méthodes de
travail ses les artisans de ce secteur
forment une catégorie spécifique nous on
essaie de s'en sort mieux financièrement
nous irons à la rencontre de trois
artisans mehdi ferronnier d'art françois
de maître verrier eric rebière
mais tout d'abord nous retrouver aussi
diverti est en charge notamment des
métiers d'art à la chambre des métiers
et de l'artisanat de versailles
sylvie berti bonjour bonjour les métiers
anciens utilise des techniques
traditionnelles
quel est l'intérêt l'intérêt d'utiliser
des techniques traditionnelles permet de
conserver à savoir faire traditionnels
qui sont des savoir faire parfois très
complexes qui utilise aussi parfois
d'élus matière ou si traditionnels ou
voir des outils traditionnels on a
certains artisans qui reconstitue des
outils l'ancien pouvoir travailler à
l'ancienne donc ça permet de conserver
ce patrimoine
ça permet également de toucher des
marchés très spécifiques notamment le
luxe la décoration habitat de participer
à la restauration du patrimoine aussi
donc voilà il ya eu énormément d'intérêt
alors finalement il est très difficile
trouver des données sur les métiers
anciens
puisqu'il n'y a pas de catégories
spécifiques pour eux il n'y a pas de
catégories métiers anciens on en a marre
des catégories effectivement métiers
d'art puisque les métiers leurs dans
l'artisanat sont référencés il ya 217
métiers de l'artisanat d'art mais la
notion de métiers anciens effectivement
est très difficile là il faudrait aller
sur place n'hésitez toutes les
entreprises et et voir effectivement
comment elle travaille mais on a des
métiers là qui innove qui font qu'ils
travaillent sont et éthiques très
moderne et d'autres technique très
ancienne
donc c'est difficile effectivement vers
perte est de savoir la part finalement
dans les métiers d'art de métiers
anciens
alors il existe tout de même des titres
des labels qui valorise les métiers
anciens
pour nous en parler
on a bien sûr au sein des chambres de
métiers de titres d'artisans ou de
maître artisan en métier d'art
donc là qui sent qu'ils sont le résultat
en fait ben d'une expérience
professionnelle voire d'un diplôme au
niveau national vous avez le titre de
maître d'art donc là c'est à titre
honorifique qui est délivrée par le
ministère de la culture et qui engage
par contre le maître d'art à former un
jeune pendant trois ans on a le label le
pv entreprise du patrimoine vivant voilà
est en fait qui est là pour récompenser
en fait une entreprise qui détient un
patrimoine économique mais un patrimoine
économique fondé sur des savoir-faire
complexes souvent rats aussi ancien et
qui va permettre de valoriser des
techniques assez complexe de mehdi
mallié le ferronnier d'art que l'on
rentrera plus tard à d'ailleurs obtenu
en fait ce label oui et il sera
peut-être prochainement maître d'art il
a fait une demande en ce sens on
attendra les résultats
sylvie berthier merci nous allons
maintenant découvrir quelques-uns de ses
métiers anciens on vous parlait de mehdi
mallié nous sommes allés dans son
atelier de ferronnerie d'art à montigny
il et travaille le métal depuis 15 ans
mehdi mallié bonjour bonjour vous êtes
ferronnier d'art nous voici dans votre
atelier vous y fabriquer notamment des
rampes ou des portails en métal alors
concrètement comment vous y prenez-vous
alors on s'y prendre la façon suivante
en commençant par un dessin qu'on reçoit
du décorateur ou l'architecte convard et
interprétée à notre façon et ensuite on
passe à la fabrication à la forge ou
dans les autres postes de travail quand
il n'y a pas de travail par le feu voilà
alors on obtient trahi par le feu par
exemple vous frappez voilà on va
travailler le métal comme cet effet il
ya déjà plusieurs siècles la même façon
à l'enclume et à chaud et maintenant on
s'aide de quelques machines pour
faciliter les tâches à ces machines
quelles sont elles
les machines seller presse un des
marteaux pilons
des cintreuse à trois c'est vraiment
différent à froid oui voilà à froid il
n'y a pas de travail par le feu donc ça
va être plus soit du perçage du tarot
d'âge des assemblages diverses de
l'usinage ces techniques qui existent
également
oui enfin qui se sont améliorées au fil
des époques qui sont assez vieillot
c'est quoi si ce métier manuel qui vous
plaît dans votre métier
oui le côté création le côté
de conception et
de faire la réalisation de ce qu'on a
créé justement quand on pense à des
métiers anciens
on se demande si votre savoir-faire sert
plus à la restauration ou à la création
vous c'est vraiment de la création
principalement de la création mais ça
arrive qu'on fasse de la restauration
s'imaginer les clients imagine mais on
interprète souvent en fait un style qui
existe c'est un peu comme la mode voilà
c'est toujours des courants qui
reviennent et on s'inspire beaucoup de
la période art déco ou pour la
ferronnerie l'époque
louis 15 oui 16 alors au niveau de la
formation
est-ce que c'est finalement un savoir
faire qui s'apprend à l'école ou qui se
transmet de fer oignons ferronnier il ya
plusieurs branches
la principale c'est l'éducation
nationale par le biais de centres de
formation et aussi par le biais du
compagnonnage juin faisant en effectuant
un tour de france en changeant fait de
ville tous les ans pour aller dans une
autre entreprise une nouvelle entreprise
et à chaque fois on a des cours en fait
par les compagnons voilà et après dans
les entreprises on est épaulé par des
plus anciens donc voilà c'est le but
aujourd'hui ventre entreprises s'en
sortent très bien vous vendez à 80 % à
l'international
comment vous expliquer cette réussite
alors la réussite allait venu petit à
petit c'est parce que voilà on met
beaucoup d'amour dans ce qu'on fait ça
se ressent et on vient nous chercher
pour ça finalement vous travaillez pour
des particuliers mais ça marche plus par
un réseau professionnel qui vient le
chercher
indirectement c'est un particulier mais
on travaille que en fait des décorateurs
des architectes et quelques
collectivités locales pour ce qui est
partie restauration
enfin des musées voilà musée mairie
enfin vos clients recherchent un une
oeuvre d'art une pièce unique
1 les deux on cherche surtout un bruit
quelque chose d'esthétique
oui l'esthétique qui fonctionne parce
qu'on est aussi on a des contraintes qui
sont liées au bâtiment des fois on peut
fabriquer les fenêtres avec un décor
dedans donc faut qu'on sache créé une
fenêtre mais aussi créer le décor mehdi
mallié merci beaucoup merci à vous nous
allons nous rendre maintenant à l'éclair
de verre un atelier de verrerie où
françoise maintenant se charge de créer
des vitraux
alors des costa est plus celui ci pour
françoise le travail du verre est une
passion devenue son quotidien
cet ancien salarié du monde de l'édition
a choisi de changer de vie il ya
quelques années pour vivre de son
activité artistique
aujourd'hui françoise est beaucoup
sollicité une de ses activités la
restauration de vitraux comme ce panneau
dont une pièce a été cassé là bas j'ai
été obligé de refaire la pièce dans son
intégralité mais en faisant des
recherches économiques de des documents
de l'époque au niveau graphisme et des
façons de travailler du 16ème siècle
pas évident quand l'original a disparu
ici françoise à utiliser du verre
soufflé à la bouche et pour les pigments
du jaune d'argent notamment un matériau
typique de cette époque mais notre
maître verrier ne s'arrête pas à cette
seule activité
on va bien au delà du vitrail simple en
fait des objets ronfler des objets en
relief des sculptures des on peut
l'intégrer à d'autres matériaux en
matière de création c'est assez magique
le vert françoise créé par exemple des
sculptures en fusing une technique qui
empile plusieurs couches de verre
ce masque est réalisé par thermoformage
à haute température
le vert épousent le moule en plus de ses
créations pour des églises des
collectivités ou des particuliers
françoise enseignent ces techniques un
moyen pour elle de transmettre ce savoir
faire ancestral
après la ferronnerie et les vitraux nous
finissons ses portraits d'artisans avec
eric poil peau un relieur basée à
rambouillet bonjour bonjour vous
connaissez les techniques
traditionnelles de la reliure elle vous
servent dans vos différentes activités
notamment la relire à l'ancienne
absolument c'est à dire le travail sur
des livres anciens avec les méthodes et
les techniques de l'époque et les
matériaux surtout de façon à réaliser au
plus proche possible de livres l'époque
par exemple comme par exemple cet
ouvrage qui était arrivé en très mauvais
état et sur lequel j'ai pu coller des
papiers que j'avais récupéré d'autres
livres mettent une peau neuve que j'ai
patiné à l'ancienne récupérer la dorure
et même faire refaire des papiers par
une marbre aux actuels qui fait d'être
papier à l'ancienne à l'identique de ce
qu'on lui fournit la tiens voilà
absolument notre activité c'est le luxe
oui quelles sont les différences et bien
le luxe va nécessiter des techniques
plus modernes toujours manuel avec des
matériaux aussi plus actuel et on va
chercher l'excellence dans la technique
et la réalisation et ça se rapproche un
peu avec les livres des décors ça se
rapproche accueillir les corps c'est un
premier pas vers la ligue 2 les corps
qu'on appelle aussi une livre objet ou
là on va demander une création une
recherche de matériaux une recherche de
dessin on va faire des maquettes des
réalisations et
pour donner quelque chose d'une pièce
unique aucune votre quatrième et
dernière activité c'est finalement la
volière du classique
je suis par avoir une plus large
clientèle pour pouvoir répondre un petit
peu à tout ce qui m'est demandé plus du
fait la religion de lui serrer coûte
relativement cher pour le commun des
mortels donc si on veut conserver un
livre on peut le flanc c'est une façon
de petits centres et clients sont
toujours présents oui bien sûr toujours
présent c'est un petit peu plus dure
depuis un an ou deux d'une façon
générale à part le luxe prévu que c'est
la création
disons que le marché se transforme vous
avez vu autour de vous des ateliers
fermé oui les petits ateliers avec très
peu d'employés ça a été très dur pour
eux dernier hambourg et que je pense que
par rapport au moment j'ai commencé on
est 50 à 100 fois moins vous vous en
sortez grâce à cette activité de luxe je
m'en sors pas ce que je suis seul je
m'en sors parce que j'ai une activité
différence et j'ai plusieurs cordes à
mon arc et notamment le luxe la rue
l'ancienne et décors effectivement qui
m'amène du travail plus régulièrement
justement cette diversité d'activités
elle s'explique aussi par votre
formation
il ya la formation et l'expérience bien
sûr j'ai fait l'école estienne ensuite
avant de m'installer pendant plus d'une
année j'ai dû faire ça tout misé atelier
de reliure différents donc forcément
j'ai appris différentes techniques
différentes méthodes différents état
d'esprit par rapport au métier qui
permet de se forger ses propres
techniques aussi ses propres direction
c'est finalement un métier en paix de
transmission complètement complètement
on a absolument besoin de transmettre et
de recevoir de différentes personnes
j'ai un employeur qui avait déjà dans
les 80 ans qui m'a dit qu'il en
apprenait encore tous les jours ça c'est
assez passionnant
éric pallot merci beaucoup je vous en
prie
ces verres finis on vous retrouve en
cette fin de nîmes héros alors nous
venons de voir trois artisans qui ont
exercé des activités finalement bien
différente au niveau de leur réussite
économique
est ce que on peut trouver un lien entre
eux est ce que finalement c'est leur
activité qui leur permet de s'en sortir
ou c'est autre chose à l'activité
effectivement a son importance et encore
une fois leur savoir faire ont fait
important c'est ce qui effectivement le
fondement de leur de leur développement
mais est ce qu'on peut parler également
de la typologie des marchés ce que l'on
remarque donc en général sur l'artisanat
d'art c'est que ceux qui ont bâti une
clientèle par dons de particuliers
uniquement ou parfois plus de
difficultés ce qu'ils doivent
démultiplier effectivement le nombre de
clients un sachant que la conjoncture
n'est pas forcément savoir non plus à
l'achat de produits d'artisanat d'art
parcours d'effectivement quand ils
travaillent les professionnels hors sur
le département on constate à peu près la
moitié des professionnels de retiendra
retravailler avec des professionnels il
ya possibilité de développement a priori
a priori plus facile effectivement quand
ils sont un marché professionnel donc on
entend par professionnels décorateurs
designers architectes etc
et puis bien sûr tous qu'il est encore
une fois mis à la restauration du
patrimoine où il a effectivement eu
aussi beaucoup de choses à faire c'est
liberty merci nos besoins tri et la fin
de ce fil est qu merci de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve pour un prochain
numéro le 26 avril